nine-month-old shaquina died in October
not long after this video was taken
she's one of almost 200 young children
in Indonesia whose kidneys were damaged
after ingesting medicinal syrup
containing toxic chemicals
my daughter died on October the 14th I
miss her all the time she always wanted
to be close to me
authorities say the contaminated
products contained dangerous levels of
ethylene glycol and diethylene glycol
liquids used in antifreeze the syrups
were recalled and now shaquina's family
is one of 25 demanding Justice the class
action lists 11 parties as responsible
including pharmaceutical companies
chemical suppliers the National Drug
regulator and the Ministry of Health
they're asking for almost a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars for each child
who died and 68 thousand dollars for
those who were injured
son died just a month after his eighth
birthday
as mothers you can't ask when will you
stop feeling sad when will you move on
we can't move on now we are here because
we have to fix something if we keep
quiet other children may become victims
in the future
this is just a procedural hearing to
check documentation but the family say
it's an important first step and have
invited other parents to join their case
the families are also asking the
government to cover in full the medical
expenses of the children suffering from
acute kidney injury to help alleviate
some of the financial stress many are
now facing
some of the survivors have severe
neurological damage and cognitive
impairment their parents say they were
healthy children who now can no longer
walk talk and eat and are almost
completely unresponsive
there are so many treatments that are
not covered by the public health
insurance that's why we are asking to
classify this as an extraordinary event
so all the expenses can be fully covered
Desi per matasari has spent the past
five months at her daughter shayna's
Hospital bedside
what mother's heart wouldn't break my
healthy girl used to run around now she
can only lie down she needs a breathing
a they made a hole in her throat and she
has to drink through a tube
the parents say they find comfort and
support in one another as together they
seek Justice for their children Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Jakarta